you mentioned Marx's view of History
it's kind of interesting to just briefly
talk about what do you think of it what
do you think of this um Marx's view of
how the different systems evolve from
the perspective of class struggles we
were talking about well I fundamentally
I'm a Marxist I fundamentally believe in
in the broad Contours of of historical
materialism
but I think we should be clear of what
Marxist theory tells us and what it
doesn't tell us you know I think Marxist
theory tells us pertinent things about
how societies have evolved about how the
distributional resources work in any
given Society who owns who doesn't how
um the conflict distributional conflicts
and so on I think Marxism can tell tell
us a lot cause Surplus is distributed
exactly exactly
what it can tell us is like
um as a friend put it like the a sex
appeal of blue jeans or whatever else
you know that that's that's beyond what
Marxism is meant to do what economic
system can tell us about the sex appeal
of blue jeans no economic system but
socialism in the Soviet sense when it
was turned into you know the
soviet-style dialectical materialism was
meant to tell us everything from
um you know explain uh genetics and
Agriculture and whatever else
um in a very disastrous way you know so
I definitely don't believe in the
application of these these ideas in an
extremely wide uh way and also I'm a
Marxist because it's a framework that
helps me understand pertinent facts
about the world
um if at some point I no longer think so
think the framework is doing that I will
not be a Marxist but I'm a socialist on
normative grounds because I have certain
beliefs about the equality of people
because I I believe in it we should have
a society with Liberty with equality
with fraternity
and that I hope I'll always be a
socialist until the day I die but it's
kind of a very un uh scientific or
unserious thing to say this is my
framework from beginning to end you know
for the rest of my life but from a
perspective history you should say that
so Mark says that you go through
societies go through different stages
it could be crudely summarizes uh
primitive communism
imperialism maybe slave Society
feudalism
uh defined by mercantilism
and then capitalism and socialism and
finally uh stateless communism communism
is am I there I miss something there I
mean I think that was that was close
enough I mean I think that's definitely
uh true of of Marxist theory that the
contradictions of capitalism
the fact that it has brought together
all these workers uh all these materials
and whatever else and it's now allowing
it to socially create wealth on a mass
scale
but that wealth is that process is being
privately uh directed and also the
Surplus is being privately kind of
appropriated
um is a contradiction and that would
lead to uh some sort of rebellion or
revolution or change and we'll have and
eventually this contradiction would be a
federal production too so we would have
to move uh into socialist uh Society but
actually just to backtrack so in terms
of contradiction so it starts when we're
in a village hunter-gatherers that's
what you call primitive communism where
everyone's kind of equal it's kind of a
collective right all right maybe you
could just just let me hold on a second
and then inequalities form of different
flavors so that's what imperialism is is
one dude Rises to the top and has some
control of different flavor that's what
feudalism with when you have one dude at
the top and you have Merchants doing
some trading and so on and then that
leads to capitalism we have private
ownership of companies and they do some
they they result in some kind of class
inequality and eventually
that results in a revolution that says
no that's this inequality is not okay
it's not natural it doesn't respect the
value of human beings and therefore it
goes to socialism where there is
under Marx's View
I guess some role for the state
the state is doing some redistribution
and then the pure communism at the end
is when it's uh
you know like it's a collective where
there's no State centralized power
so is this what's part of that is wrong
no I think and broadly the the Marxist
theory of History
is about different types different modes
of of of production that existed various
times
um based on material
um conditions so in the early times in
this this Theory
um there was not much Surplus being
generated right and there was generally
egalitarian societies
I then
um as we became agricultural as Society
developed there was more Surplus being
produced
and then there was a group of people the
ruling classes of their their age that
controlled and distributed that that
controlled that division of labor and
appropriated more of that Surplus for
themselves and they weren't involved in
productive labor in early print of
society everybody's involved in
productive labor later on you had casts
of priests who did nothing but kind of
pray and write and and kind of lecture
people all day right and you had
um Kings and rulers and bureaucrats and
traitors and so on you have a more
complex division of labor but also more
inequity
um driving out of that
um
capitalism was a revolutionary system
because it took away one it made us
tremendously more productive right it
expanded production beyond our wildest
imaginations
but it also no longer bound uh workers
to their lord or manner or whatever else
they were now free to move free to
engage in contracts with employers and
and and so on
um but even though workers are now
producing all this tremendous wealth and
even though productive forces have been
matured in such a way
they were ultimately taken away from all
the wealth they were created they got
some of it back they were in wealthy
societies but they were all there
collectively together producing this
wealth and that was a potent Force so
Marx theorized that would lead to a
revolutionary change in a in a socialist
Direction I think in fact what we saw
was that
yes workers are dependent on
on capitalists are depend on workers
but the dependency is
um
obviously symmetrical in the sense that
workers are also dependent on
capitalists but in fact it's an
asymmetrical dependency and that
ordinary workers need their jobs more
than capitalists need the contribution
of individual workers so it became kind
of a collective action problem
where you would need the massive workers
to get together to decide to change
things but also people be afraid because
they'd be dependent on their jobs for
their livelihood and so on so Revolution
became a lot harder than people thought
especially in Democratic countries where
workers had certain outlets and certain
powers and rights and responsibility you
know it's no surprise that where you did
have socialist revolutions they were in
places like
um the third world post-colonial
colonial states trying to emerge out of
colonialism
um they were in places like you know
China and Russia autocratic countries
and never in a advanced capitalist
country
now
in Marx's theory of History even as
interpreted by a lot of smart marxists
like uh GA Cohen and others
um there is a certain inevitability to
socialism after capitalism the way that
I would put it myself is I kind of have
a more I guess you could say like Kanti
and view of it like I think socialism is
something that ought to happen
but it's not something that necessarily
will happen and we'll need to organize
and persuade and also potentially again
the key part of any social system that's
Democratic is you have to allow for the
possibility of a democratic revision to
a different sort of system so I'd be
more than happy in my vision of
socialism for there to be capitalist
parties
um getting you know in my hopefully
three four five percent of the vote
maybe a lot more in the same way that in
the U.S or Republic we could right now
have a monarchist party no one's going
to support a moniker Sparty in the in
the US in serious
um numbers although that's gaining
popularity in Europe or else no in uh
isn't there in the anarchist tradition
isn't there aren't they saying that one
of the ways you could have a leaders in
monarchy because they're more directly
responsible to the citizens if you have
a leader it's healthier to have a
monarch anyway I'm not yeah I've heard
this stated the left-wing Anarchist
Traditions like um anarchosynicalism or
whatever else like that their slogan is
kind of
um no Kings no Gods no Masters or
whatever so no bosses so they they
definitely would not agree with that but
I'm you know not familiar enough
anarchism is runs a gamut from left to
right and interesting way I'll I'll have
to ask about it I'll have to ask you
about that but yeah okay so you're uh
you're not you don't believe Marx's
theory of history in the sense that it
everything every stage is a natural
consequence of every other stage of
course he would predict that somebody
like you must exist in order for the for
the those stages to go from one to the
next because you might because you have
to believe ought
in order for Action to be taken to
inspire the populace to take actions so
two things one is I do broadly believe
in Marxist theory of History because
it's just explaining how uh productive
forces develop and the relations of
production in any uh given system
I guess there's a theory of transition
from capitalism to socialism that Marx
didn't really spell out but it was kind
of implied they it would naturally
happen and Marx was living in an era of
tremendous upheaval you know Marx
himself actually saw when he was living
in in London in the 1870s uh the Paris
commune when workers took over for just
a few months but they took over the
producers of Paris took over the city
basically created their own government
their own system
um and so on so he was living through an
era of upheaval and angles especially
over song was the mentor to all these
Rising
um socialist parties so he was very
close closely collaborating with
socialists in places like Britain and
Germany when they were drafting their
first programs
um for the Social Democratic party so
it felt like this was gonna happen it
felt like this Rising working class
would take power but I think the
stability of the system was
underestimated it's easy to see the
contradictions in the system but can you
see its mechanisms of stability
um the way in which
um Mass Collective action or revolution
is more the exception or the the norm
could you imagine if your marks not only
how much wealth the system would produce
over time uh which I think he could have
imagined but also developments like the
welfare state and mass democracy and
universal suffrage which might have
changed how workers um
relate to the system or operate
um within it so I think it's just it's
just the transition part that I think
wasn't spelled out properly but I think
in either case
as socialists we can assume that history
is working in our favor we just need to
kind of hold out and and wait for the
inevitable uh Revolution we have to
convince people of both one the struggle
for day-to-day reforms and why it's
important to be politically organized
why it's important to be a member of a
union or to advocate for things like a
universal healthcare or whatever else to
try to kind of build the cohesion and
sense of self of the the class
I then ultimately
for the desirability once we accomplish
it once we build social democracy of
going Beyond social democracy which is
of course the challenge now I don't
think it requires leadership from the
outside I think there are plenty of
organic leaders that have emerged from
the working class that have advocated
for for socialism uh from the working
class and if you look at the class
composition during the Glory Days of the
European socialist parties I mean this
was very much a working class
um parties and organizations it's only
been the last like 30 years that it's
been taken over by professionals and you
know not on coincidentally you know they
they have um uh accomplished very little
in those those 30 years